bonsoir j'ai reçu une invitation pour en
concert où j'irai faire la connaissance
de trois musiciens avec lesquels je
serai amené à travailler
une invitation c'est magique
au moment de la présentation
je donne la main et me font la bise
je donne la main il m'offrant la bise je
donne la main ils me font la bise
pourquoi les musiciens ses trois
musiciens ont choisi de me faire la bise
au lieu de me serrer la main parce
qu'ils veulent protéger le grand alain
qui se tache dans leurs mains des
musiciens virtuoses la petite idée
amusante fait le chemin jusque d'encre
et puis le soir quand je m'endors je
fais ce rêve dans le rêve que je fais je
suis en train d'attendre le grand
musicien glenn gould dans ces loges
je tient d'une main un magnifique
bouquet de fleurs à offrir et de l'autre
le fameux enregistrements des variations
goldberg
de jean sébastien bach tu que je veux
faire dédicacer par glenn lui même c'est
alors qu'arrive trois personnages
inquiétants
il porte de grandes ou noir des chapeau
feutre noir et tiennent chacun un grand
attache thèse et il s'adresse à moi en
ces termes monsieur et gamma palandri
glenn gould a eu un empêchement
alors vous avez été choisi pour le
remplacer sur scène séance tenante à bon
comment ça je n'ai jamais touché un
piano demain comment voulez vous que je
fasse prendre un bain ce billy mongomin
baby by me mbaye et baby limengo veux tu
es un bon moment
bon bah ça babylim engomer yé yé yé vtm
bongo au fur et à mesure que je leur
signifie mon refus de monter sur scène
reviennent dans ma mémoire les souvenirs
douloureux de l'enfance quand je
refusais d'aller au tableau devant mes
petits camarades parce que j'avais peur
de prendre la parole en public parce
qu'il se trouve que j'étais bègue et que
la peur de bégayer s'est transformé en
peur de parler
jusqu'au jour où j'ai fait la rencontre
du magny à de la parole je vous parle
des chants de femmes je vous parle de la
parole du conteur hui c'est à la lecture
patiente de la partition secrète des
mots que je me suis moi même des livres
et de la peur de bégayer la peur de
chaque mais nous n'étions plus là
les trois inquiétant continue d'insister
monsieur et gamma fans andré vous n'avez
pas besoin d'être pianiste pour
remplacer glenn gould sur scène
ah bon comment ça monsieur ayant un fan
andré cesser d'avoir peur
nous avons ici tout ce qu'il vous faut
c'est alors qu'ils ont ouvert
la gran attache keys et on pouvait voir
dans un parfait alignement les mains les
mains l'humain les mains des plus grands
pianistes virtuoses du monde entier les
mains les mains les mains dans leurs
dents de soie blanche avec boutons de
manchette a sorti un doux sous le petit
écriteau les mains des glenn gould les
malins les mains les mains les mains de
jean sébastien bach lui même les mâles
mais les mains le mans d'amadeus mozart
et à côté de ma news mozart les mains de
beethoven et dans un autre ordre d'idées
les mains de duke ellington les
mandatures 15 moutons à côté des mains
de duke ellington les mains de temps ici
les mains de thelonious monk les mains
des matous cole et puis les mains des à
tâtons monsieur adama falandry vous
voyez il vous suffit maintenant d'un
chili les mains de glenn gould de monter
sur scène de poser simplement vos mains
sur le piano et vous verrez ce que vous
verrez
aussitôt dit aussitôt fait et me voici
aussi en train d'avancer sur scène comme
si de rien n'était et je me mets sur le
piano et au moment où ge posez-les m
elle commence à se balader tout seul
comme dans la famille adams les mains
balade et ça jouer comme ça tu es
[Musique]
magnifique bijou high as they do bumba
je ne regardais même que le piano je
regardais le public ce lundi mauvais
joueur
c'est à moi qu'on remet maintenant les
fleurs et puis fondu enchaîné le grand
silence des fins de concert quand le
public s'en est allé silence de mort
je ne sais pas comment je suis dans mon
propre rêve un train de lorgner par le
trou d'une serrure et je vois en
conciliabule mystérieux entre les trois
inquiétant et moi-même fin de
conciliabules qu'est ce qu'ils sont en
train de dire monsieur il ya ma femme
très bien sûr que vous pouvez garder
pour vous même les mains du grand chelem
ould à la condition que vous abandonner
définitivement les mêmes qui ont fait le
chemin avec vous jusque là ah bon mais
bien sûr monsieur adama fall andré c'est
une très belle affaire
pianiste international monsieur adama
faudrait d'abord monsieur diama falandry
il reste une condition vous devez venir
à l'enterrement de vos mains non je
n'irai pas à l'enterrement de mes mains
soit monsieur il ya ma femme engrais
j'ai vu les trois inquiétant partir avec
leurs attaches thèse mon coeur battait
la chamade dans le corbillard se
trouvaient mes mains et moi je regarde
mes gants de soie blanc
bien se gâtent l'éventreur je rentre
chez moi fin de concert un peu tard le
musicien qui rentre à la pointe des
pieds
je me mets dans mon lit et je dors dans
mon sommeil il quand je dors là mon
propre rêve
en général je ne rêve pas fondu enchaîné
nous sommes le matin je regarde mes
mains et je me dis que je vais
maintenant les découvrir elles sont bien
en moi je ne rêve pas et au moment où
j'enlève les gants de soie blanche
il n'y avait rien je me suis retrouvé
avec les deux mains tranchées plus
demain de glenn gould
c'est un orgue à ce moment là au moment
de la grande panique au moment du
jugement
j'entends au loin comme un tam-tam
d'appel à y emmenant en temps en temps
en temps en temps en bétail aux mazades
il n'a que peu pesant 1 en battant comme
un abominable que nous en bêta d'oum
azza boumilat m'pep deux ans et derrière
j'ai la vision de mes mains outre tombe
dans un tombeau que je ne connais pas
les trois inquiétants sont partis avec
mes mains et je les entends qui chante
la chanson de l'inter des mains et quand
je chante dans mon rêve ça m'apprend
total 1 et ça fait comme ça non je
n'irai pas à l'enterrement de mes mains
elle murray comme tout aux tombes me
rappelle que demain en chrysanthèmes
j'irai fleurir tout ce qui demain en
robe de terre nous attendent toujours
sans lendemain évidemment cruellement
c'est pareil
[Musique]
et moi qui croyais manger [ __ ]
enterrement assister la tamise empire le
ton extrêmement hérité de thé
victuailles en tant que ton amant non je
n'irai pas à l'enterrement de demain le
rire outre tombe tous ceux qui attaquent
demain j'irai dormir au fond d'un trou
qui sans lendemain me rées g de vous
quitter sans vous dira demain fin de mot
rêve
mes chers amis le compteur c'est le
musicien de la parole et la voix et son
instrument mais c'est surtout l'oreille
qui lui permet d'aller chercher la clé
de lecture la note clés de lecture de la
partition secrète des mots lui il ya une
musique derrière le sens des mots c'est
en prenant conscience de cette
musicalité des mots dans les chante
fable que je me suis délivrer de cette
bousculade parce que je voulais parler
trop vite je voulais aller plus vite que
la musique le conte a commencé d'abord
par à 1 g les mots selon leurs sons et
leurs sens ensuite ils les hommes dani
les ordonne et les rythmes de manière
agréable à dire et à chanter comme ça
le pied d'aubergines sur le terrain va à
20 j'imagine au lieu qu'ils diva
[Musique]
le malheur de pousser un tre 20 et marie
écrasé par tout ce qui passait par là
le pied d'aubergines sur le terrain
vague avait j'imagine rapproche cas
c'est le fruit arracher le corps sage
déchirer comme pousser sans abri sans
famille sans état sans amour sa maison
le quai du berger sur le terrain va on
nous raconte que le compte est le fils
aîné de la parole mais que le compte est
venu au monde à cause de la question
essentielle d origine homme qui es tu
d'où viens tu es vous et moi de répondre
je suis né de mon père et de ma mère et
ton père et ta mère de qui sont ils nés
ils sont nés de la paire et de leur mère
et leur père et leur mère deux qui sont
ils nés ils sont nés eux aussi de la
peur et de la mer c'est pour répondre à
cette question générale d origine que
l'être humain a interrogé la mémoire de
son sein comme ça j'ai demandé son âge
au sang qui coule dans mes veines
il m'a répondu soit sage car ta question
en vaut la peine
alors ce sens m'a promené dans le
labyrinthe infinie des hommes et des
femmes qui avant moi l'ont portée
depuis l'arrière grand père de l'arrière
grand père de mon arrière grand père qui
le tenait lui-même de l'arrière grand
père de l'arrière grand père de mon
arrière grand père qui le tenait
lui-même de l'arrière grand père de
l'arrière grand père de l'arrière grand
père de mon arrière-grand-père roma
città nano moulin obama au lendemain de
ma femme et à ma démo nous c'est un de
mourinho car tu as ta l'uqat et endemol
au utah à la mémoire de mon sens m'a
amené jusqu'aux grands payer des
poussières le pays de y était une fois
c'est le pays de la plus ancienne de nos
mémoires lorsqu'on ne sait plus qui
était le père du père du père du père du
père du père au pays des poussières
l'enfant point me dit toutes les
poussières du monde ont des liens de
parenté nécessaires à la remontée des
généalogies streit qui nous lient au puy
tout pas assez cuite
nous sommes tous des baguettes nous
sommes tous peints à la table des
régions cannibale qui donne au corps
les gars c'est depuis ce temps là que
l'on sait que le rêve du compteur c'est
de transmettre la cli de lecture de la
partition aimant la musique et des mots
je vous invite mes chers amis à penser
car tous autant que nous sommes ici nous
sommes la somme de mund immense d'hommes
et de femmes qui ont participé à la
confection de notre adn de notre
identité c'est une histoire vraie réel
en 15/100 machin
combien ont participé imaginez un seul
instant que vous ayez la possibilité
magique
convoqué toutes les poussières du monde
qui ont participé à la confection de
votre c'est ça que je rêve c'est ça que
chaque au compteur et un manga bonheur
bogdana metouali samia me veut bien où
je vous répète
[Applaudissements]